las vegas is known as the sports and
entertainment capital of the world but
when was the last time an annual
sporting event pulled out of our city
sports director chris matthews joining
us live in studio with that big news hey
chris well thank you very much christian
yeah we learned this morning that the
pbr will be pulling its annual world
finals event out of las vegas and moving
it to texas since 1994 the pbr world
finals has been held every year in las
vegas the only year it missed was last
year because of the city's strict covid
rules apparently they got a texas-sized
taste of the pbr and wanted more the pbr
has certainly changed over the years
it's transformed into a huge four-day
show and tomorrow morning the
organization will announce it's moving
to texas beginning in 2022 and will be
held in may every year there now last
year at this time the organization was
having so much trouble with navigating
the political waters here in las vegas
the ceo of the pbr says he couldn't even
get a call back from our political
leaders how hard did you work with the
state with the governor's office to try
to get some sort of resolution
well to be perfectly candid we didn't
get called calls back from the
governor's office so we worked through
our friends at lbcba mgm t-mobile
um and others to try and get the message
across that you know here's this private
company that's that's conducting events
safely and responsibly has
literally the industry-leading protocols
and we're the first out there with uh
with safe and responsible plans to
to conduct events and uh and and we just
couldn't get the time of day
all right not only is this a huge blow
to las vegas but the economic benefits
now leaving las vegas reaching to the
hundreds of millions of dollars pbr
world finals considered the super bowl
of bull riding the annual four day event
here in las vegas is coming up november
3rd through the 7th with tickets ranging
from 24 dollars all the way up to
sunday's best seats at 753 dollars